all right good afternoon everyone
welcome to my session and thank you so
much for joining I hope you're excited
for a series of surrealist demos it's
gonna be so much fun
so today we're going to look at building
several as api's using nodejs and Azure
functions and I want you all to take a
second and think about Twitter and think
about Twitter in terms of scale so every
day in fact every second we are
collectively creating 6,000 tweets
platform twitter has 330 million users
using their platform yearly we're
creating 200 billion tweets that's some
interesting stat statistics right
interesting numbers now what if the
creators of Twitter would have never
created Twitter because of the amount of
scale and the amount of users that they
had to support think about that how our
life be without Twitter that's basically
me on every single startup idea that
I've ever had I kind of thinking about
scale and the fact that I have to
implement and think about it and
implement this application that might be
used by gazillion users I'm just giving
up before even starting but that's why I
also love surrealist
because it enables me to build the next
Twitter without having to think of all
of that my name is Simona cotton and I
work as a cloud developer advocate for
Microsoft
I'm here with set for Eze and a couple
other developer advocates you can find
us on this page at AKMs avocados or on
Twitter ad advocates this is a page with
everyone and the areas that they tend to
focus on in terms of Technology
cool so what about service some of you
here that happen in the industry for
quite a while remembering the time when
we had we used to do everything on
premise and I'm sure that there's
there's still people that are doing that
yesterday at service days cardiff i
actually met someone that was saying
that they're running their own servers
from the basement of their building in
bristol so there's there are still
people that go and build their own
servers buy their own hardware and they
have to answer all these questions like
how much hardware do I need is my
hardware in a secure location how do i
architect my application am i going how
many users will I have to support with
the existing infrastructure so that's
the beginning of kind of the history of
compute and then from on-premise we
realized that actually we should be
doing something about this we shouldn't
rely on only on us buying our own
hardware maybe we should outsource that
so we started outsourcing that to this
model that's called infrastructure as a
service were basically someone else buys
the hardware and someone else makes sure
that whenever there's a hardware failure
they're going to take care of that
they're gonna replace that particular
server we don't have to worry about that
it's not an investment that we have to
make actively but turns out that that's
not enough we still have to answer
questions like what kind of security
threats do I expose myself to so is
there someone that can help me with that
and that's what platform as a service
helps us with so basically we no longer
have to maybe install and provision all
those virtual machines that we would do
in a infrastructure as a service type of
model but now we have platform as a
service where the cloud provider or the
company that we've we have outsourced
that model to they're going to make sure
to provision all the VMS that I need
they're going to install the operating
system for us and more than that they're
gonna they're actually going to even
install the security patches for
so we're pretty safe there there's not a
lot to manage but still we have to
figure out how much skill how much our
application needs to scale so we have to
make sure that we configure those
settings and not only that we also pay a
monthly bill so we pay every month a
certain amount of money even though
maybe our VM where our application
consumes only 20% or 10% or 0% at times
with that within that platform so then
welcome to today which is serverless
where we don't have to worry about any
of that the only thing the only
questions that we have to ask are how do
I architect my application and how do I
make sure that my code is secure so no
more worrying about the infrastructure
no more worrying about the web server we
only focus on the code so what is
serverless
with tremulous will basically have an
abstraction of servers we still have
servers somewhere it's just that we
don't have to take care of them we don't
have to configure them ourselves we
don't decide which web server is going
to run our application and we just have
to deploy our code to a certain platform
we we write code that it reacts to
events so for those of you who've worked
with several as before your your might
be familiar with the fact that server
list code will will react to events like
an HTTP request or maybe a file that has
been uploaded on on a storage account or
an event that has happened somewhere in
the cloud and finally well the other
thing that's absolutely important about
server list is this instant scale so the
fact that depending on the number of
users that are making requests to our
application our application can be
deployed in a single container or it can
be deployed to thousands of servers or
thousands of containers and we're going
to pay only for the amount of compute
and memory that we're using while our
application is running
so that's very important micro billing
for those of you who are just starting
to maybe build a product and you're
looking for a solution that's not gonna
make you pay a monthly bill and that's
not gonna make you configure all the
scale or all the numbers required for
your application to serve a number of
users serverless is the solution for you
but then we do have this concept of
functions when it comes to service
functions as a service and this is where
we'll write our code that's gonna
execute things and react to events but
many times we find ourselves not only
having to execute code and when it comes
up in response to an event but we also
have to execute code that kind of works
in a flow and that's what logic apps can
help us with so if you have to
orchestrate multiple events you can use
logic apps for that and on top of
orchestration logic apps also has this
concept of connectors and basically
there's house there's thousands of or
hundreds of connectors in logic apps
where we can maybe use it use them for
sending emails like logic apps
integrates with send grid for example or
office 365 and we don't have to write
the code that connects our application
to those particular api's it's already
done for us and then because it's
event-driven
we also have this thing called event
grid which allows us to orchestrate
events and interact with them but all of
this sits on top of the data sources
that I've mentioned earlier and a lot of
other tools like databases we can read
data and we can react to changes in our
database in our storage account we can
we're sure that our application is going
to be monitored for security flaws we
can interact with IOT devices and we can
monitor our application but we're all
developers right so we definitely need
to
have also the development tools that
enable us to build these applications
and with agile functions we have IT
support so ideas like visual studio or
even editor vs code as well as
integration with Azure DevOps and
monitoring application insights and
we're gonna see all of these right now
so most of the session will be hands-on
and I hope you're a huge fan of demos
and I hope that the demo gods are gonna
be with me so this is vs code how many
of you is it can you see it yeah perfect
how many of you are using this code
fantastic that's like 90% of the room
one of the biggest things with this code
so this code is the text editor that has
been built by Erich gamma and one of the
most powerful things about vs code is
extension so basically by using those
extensions we can turn our text editor
in a full ID and one of the when it
comes to Cyril is one of the most useful
extensions that you'll ever find is the
azure functions extension so this
extension is going to help us create new
projects create new functions run and
debug those functions as well as deploy
them I've already installed this
extension but basically it depends on
Azure core tools which will be installed
whenever you go through the installation
process and you have all the steps here
so I highly recommend if you're you're
getting started with server let's go
ahead and install this extension it will
be the best thing that it has ever
happened tend to be very positive okay
so once you have that extensions and
extension installed you're gonna be able
to access it from from the left-hand
side on the azure icon so right here you
can see that I have the functions
aligned there with functions
from just from here I'm able to inspect
all the functions that I have deployed
in the cloud so this is connect this
extension is listing functions that I
have in Azure portal in via a portal and
then I can also create new projects I
can create new functions and deploy them
to the cloud so let's go ahead and
create a new project now one thing
that's unique about Asha is that you are
able to deploy or write multiple
functions within a project so this will
enable us to deploy the functions that
are logically connected within the same
resource and that means that we're also
going to scale those functions together
so I've selected create a new project
and then it's gonna ask me what kind of
what programming language do I want to
use as you can see there's JavaScript
and C sharp they're generally available
and we can also use Python or Java
they're in preview mode so I'm gonna use
JavaScript and then if I go back to my
file explorer you're gonna see a couple
of files that have been created for us
the first one is the vs code folder and
this is where all the magic lives this
is where our configuration for running
and debugging functions is I'm not gonna
go into detail you don't have to know
anything about configuring vs code we
just know that it's there and it's gonna
run for us the next thing that has been
generated is the hot host of JSON file
this is where you configure settings
that are available
our global to your project things like
what kind of version of the azure
functions runtime am i using I'm using
the second version because that's the
one that is supported on all operating
systems I can also configure here things
like what's the root of my if if I'm
configuring if I'm running an HTTP
function then I can configure the the
root of the route that I that my URL
will have so generally it's gonna be by
default it's going to be API but we can
change that we can do
API or we can change it to let's say MVC
another an important file here is the
local that settings that jason this is
where we configure our application
settings that we want to use in our
local so imagine when you you're
building functions or projects that you
run in your local you want to connect
your developer database development
database when you move into the cloud
you'll probably want to connect to your
production database if that's your
production environment so this is where
you can configure your database
connection string and then proxies this
is a new feature well not really new
it's been around for probably more than
a year and this is how we can create a
thin layer on top of our existing
function app or we can actually even
group multiple function apps within the
same proxy as your functions proxy I
don't have an example for that but if
you want to talk about more about this
we can tell after this session so then
the next step this is just the the
project that we've created next we want
to actually go ahead and create a new
function and I've used the the icon
there with the Thunder and the plus and
that will help me create a new function
and generate code for that function from
predefined templates so here and
previously that with Azure functions and
with circulars we react to events so
here you can see that we can create
functions that react to HTTP requests or
to changes in a blob storage account or
even to a cue storage or a service bus
bus and even timer trigger so we can
generate functions that will run at a
certain time interval but because we're
building api's I'm gonna create an HTTP
trigger function and then I have to give
it a name so I'm gonna name it read
recipes and you're gonna see why later
and the authorization level here
anonymous it means that the URL will be
accessible to everyone
function means that you will the the
platform will generate a code for
and unless that particular URL is being
called with that code you won't go get
access so if you run it without that
code you will get a four a one saying
that permission is denied and this is
all handled by the platform itself so
that's you don't have to do anything for
that and then admin means that only my
subscription will be able to call into
this function and this can be useful
when you want to guard your your code
you wanted to run in a certain
environment but for me it doesn't really
matter I'm gonna go with anonymous and
now we have a new folder that has been
created and that has the same name as
the function that we've generated so
then function that jason this is where
our function configuration yes so you
see that we have an array of bindings
and we've defined two different bindings
one is an input binding and it's the
HTTP trigger so this is how we tell the
azure runtime that we're listening for
HTTP requests that are coming in and
then with the second one we are defining
the output binding and this is how we
tell the azure functions runtime that we
are returning an HTTP response and then
our index that J is file this is a
JavaScript function that will get two
parameters the first one is the context
object which will enable us to
communicate with the runtime and the
second one is basically the first
element in the bindings array and it's
also the request object and you can see
here that I'm using context to log
information and then I'm checking
whether name exists either on the
request parameters or the request body
and if it does I'm gonna return a hello
something if it doesn't I'm gonna return
an error so who's excited to have this
baby running yeah so I'm going to run
this I can either go to this debug panel
or I can even start the command palette
so command shift P and then say I want
to start debugging so what this will do
is if we look at the terminal we can see
that the first thing that it will do is
install extensions so the new edge of
functions runtime is using an extension
based kind of model where we only have
in the core of the platform we only have
probably the HTTP trigger implemented
that I'm not sure if even that one and
then the rest of the extensions are
going we're going to have to install
them ourselves and the runtime will
actually scan the function that JSON
file and see what kind of bindings were
using and based on that it will go ahead
and install those bindings the next
thing that will happen is it will run
func host start which starts the actual
runtime and one thing that I want you to
note here the array functions runtime
it's it's actually open source so
whatever runs in the cloud we can
actually run in our local we're running
in our local as well and this is what
enables us to debug applications locally
and once it started because this is an
HTTP function it will also generate a
URL that we can use in our application
so I can click on this and it will open
a browser telling me that I need to pass
in a parameter so here we can see that
I've passed a name equals several eyes
and it returns hello service but what if
we want to debug this well I go back to
my IDE
can add a breakpoint let's say here if
request name maybe I have a bug and I
want to debug this so if I'm refreshing
now it will stop at the breakpoint I've
just added and then I can inspect these
variables maybe I can change the query
to be instead of serverless I can say no
I can say set and then run this and it
will say hello say so this is the primer
of what you can do in your local with
Azure functions but what we said is that
we're gonna add we're gonna go ahead and
build api's right and this is this is
just an endpoint it doesn't do much so
I'm gonna use this thing called code
snippets from vs code I how many of you
are familiar with the concept of the
code snippets in base code awesome
there's probably a half of the room for
the rest of the half you can basically
write if you have code that you're
constantly writing having to write
yourself you can actually use code
snippets to generate that code and
you're gonna see what how it works so
I've I've just typed read and then I'm
selecting read recipes and then this
will use the snippet that I've added in
my comfy so you can see here that I'm
basically I'm importing the MongoDB
package so my API my API endpoint will
read data from a MongoDB database and it
will return a list of recipes and the
reason why I'm doing that is because I
have this awesome angular application
called tacos UI and right now if I go
into tacos
let me inspect element here if I go into
tacos you will see that I'm returning a
list of tacos recipes
but in fact this is a JSON up this this
is a JSON file that I'm reading so it's
not very dynamic what I want to do
instead is basically go and read data
from a cosmos DB database so cosmos DB
is a no sequel database that supports
different types of models we can query
cosmos to be using the sequel API a
MongoDB API graph API and there's a
couple more I think of Sandra as well
but the cool thing is that cosmo ZB has
an extension as well and cuz in vs code
and right here I can go ahead and see
all the databases that I have available
I can even inspect here and this is one
document that I've created and I can
even update it right here in visco I
think this is awesome
but going back into our application what
I really want to do is instead of
requesting data from a JSON file I
actually want to connect this
application to a service endpoint and
the way I'm gonna do that is I'm gonna
deploy this application to the cloud and
then connect to that URL okay so first
of all we are looking at this code very
quickly we are importing a MongoDB
package and this is where when I got
started with service I had to think like
okay I know how to build applications
with no GS I know how to install
applications how to install packages in
a normal node.js application but how do
I actually install packages in a
serverless application and turns out
that the answer is quite simple I have
to run NPM in it - why to create a new
package that JSON file and I need to
create it at the root folder of my of my
project so if you look here I've
generated I've created a new package
that JSON file and then the next thing
that I can do is run NPM install MongoDB
and this will install the MongoDB
package for me and save it
in the package that JSON file and I also
have access to the node modules folder
very important here probably this has
changed in the past year where basically
I'm sharing all the node modules between
all of my functions so this is this is
valuable information because I'm not
replicating I'm not duplicating packages
before that we used to have to install
packages for each function that we were
creating
okay so we've learned how to create how
to install NPM packages in our functions
awesome what's the next thing that we're
doing here we are defining an
authentication object with the user and
the password and then initializing a TV
object to now and then we have this low
DB function that basically checks
whether the DB object is null if it
isn't it will just return otherwise it
will attempt to connect to it to the
database that we've seen earlier and
then return that object and once I have
the DB object I'm gonna go ahead and
read from the recipes collection turn
that into an array and return that as
part of our response object so this is
something that you've probably seen
before if you've used no GS or if you've
ever read from a database before one
thing that I want to highlight here is
the fact that we are initializing this
object outside our function scope this
means that we are attempting to reuse
the database connection throughout a
user requests with simulus we cannot
store state so state will always if we
want to store state somewhere we're
gonna have to restore to storage
somewhere in the database or a queue or
a blob storage because we don't have
access to the local memory and apart
from that the service provider will tell
you that actually you can only run your
function for 10 minutes and after that
we can move your function to a
completely different instance
a different part of the world maybe so
you cannot rely on local state but
thinking optimistically most of the
times that particular function will be
in the same instance for probably 15
minutes and or 30 minutes so if we can
gain some performance here it's
recommended that you do it so I ran some
tests here and without reusing this
database connection I was spending
probably 300 milliseconds more on each
request because if we would always
initialize that connection okay awesome
so we've installed the MongoDB package
and we have all the details here to
connect to a database let's see if that
actually works so I go ahead and run the
function that we've just created and
this will start the edge of functions
run time and then I can click on the
link there and yay it has connected to
my database and it's returns data from
that particular database just to make
sure that things are I'm not cheating
here I'm gonna go ahead and delete all
these it's nobody likes exclamation
marks right so I've deleted these from
cosmos DB so now if i refresh the page
we shouldn't have these anymore which is
true we only have one probably if i
refresh again hopefully yeah we left one
there awesome so we have connected to
our database what's the next step well I
have to if some of you are secure our
super concerned about security probably
already you've raised the proud brow
here when you saw that I'm actually
displaying my database connection in my
code what if we commit this to github so
what I had what we can do now is move
those connection strings to our local
that settings that JSON file so let's
say I'm taking my password here and
moving it to local that settings that
JSON
password I'm saving this here and I
already know that I also have a user and
that is tacos okay and I also need the
port which I think it's this one so the
port for connecting to our database we
can find it here yeah I think it was a
correct one oh okay so I've saved all
these settings here but how do we how do
we go and access them from our
application you already know this again
we can use process dot m and I want to
take a note of this star that means that
after visco has run some machine
learning on a lot of people using a lot
of usage in vs code they've decided that
M is one of the most popular fields
accessed from process so if you've
updated to the latest version of es code
you're gonna have access to this as well
so process that and the password and
then we said that we're gonna replace
here the user as well okay user and here
notice that I'm using a backtick which
allows me to use this interpolation
notation I'm not sure if that's the
correct name process that m dot user and
then our port we're gonna do exactly the
same thing
process that that port okay so instead
of connecting hard coding the connection
strings in our code we have moved them
to this local that settings that JSON
file I'm gonna run this again just to
double check that everything is working
as expected
and from here the next thing that we
want to do is go ahead and connect our
at the angular application to read data
from our service endpoint so just
testing okay fantastic we're retrieving
the correct data we have access to this
URL so in order to connect our angular
application to our endpoint I have to go
and replace the URL that I have defined
in my angular service let me with the
URL that my service endpoint has
generated so this is everything I need
to do to replace an existing back-end
with the service one and now if i
refresh the page on the takos UI boomer
i'm gonna act surprised it looks like we
have caused issues so then the next
question is yeah
we are accessing from a different domain
so we have to set up course so the next
thing that we have to do is go ahead and
do that in our service application and
to set up course I have to I can do that
in local that settings that JSON right
here I have this host property which
enables me to define course so this is
how I would enable course in my local
and then in order to we can do that in
the portal as well where we can define
course but let's see if this works now
so the the function is running if i
refresh the page fantastic its retrieved
data from our database and I can run the
exact same test where I modify one of
the fields and the database and then
refresh the page here but it doesn't
it's not as useful anymore you've seen
that it works so then the next thing
that we want to do everything works in
our local we actually want to deploy
this to the clock right so that it's
accessible to those million users that
would want to use our application and as
I mentioned the azure functions
extension allows us to go ahead and
deploy this application directly to the
to the cloud I've clicked the blue arrow
there and then I already have a function
app that I've created and I can select
that so that I can deploy my code there
but as you can see here there's a
warning it's asking me whether I really
want to deploy this application this
will overwrite existing code as one of
our colleagues and friends says friends
don't let other friends right click
deploy right because this is danger zone
even if you're working by yourself this
is gonna be a problem whether you want
to keep version control you want to keep
versions of your code you want to make
sure you're not overwriting everything
and it's not retrievable so I'm gonna
cancel this and I'm gonna show you one
neat thing that I've learned this
weekend so I've been struggling with arm
templates how many of you have used arm
templates as your resource manager
template basically infrastructure as a
code so with arm templates we can
actually define all the resources that
we are using whenever we're creating a
function app and it's repeatable and
reusable deployments I've been trying
for a year to generate those arms for
function apps and I've been failing
successfully every single time but this
weekend it's worked so I'm gonna show
you how to do that there's another
extension that can help you with this
it's called agile resource manager tools
and if you have it installed in your vs
code the first thing that you can do is
search the agile resource manager
template quick starts on github so
there's a repository on github with
hundreds of templates to generate these
resources and the I have to enter a
search term so that it knows what kind
of template I'm looking for and I've
searched for function and I can create I
can use a template that creates a
dedicated plan which is the app service
and it's the monthly bill we don't want
that we want the dynamic plan so I'm
selecting the dynamic one and it's
created a new folder and templates with
the name of the function and then in
parameters I can define the name I can
define a parameter for what we'll see in
the next file but let's say NDC London
five so this is this string is gonna be
part of our URL which is available
globally so it has to be unique that's
why I use NDC London five I already
deployed a couple of them so I'm saving
this and then looking at Azure deploy
that Jason this is where the magic
happens this is where we define we
declare the resources that we want to
deploy and right here in this code we
have a Jason
outline and this is gonna walk us
through the main elements of a a sure
deploy file so the first thing that we
can we have to define in a template RM
template is the schema this jason is
going to be validated against the schema
to tell us whether what we're about to
deploy is correct or not the next thing
is the content version this is where we
version the template so this is our
version the list of parameters this is
what we're going to use in order to make
things dynamic so imagine here we have
one of the parameters is the app name
I'm actually going to show you
this with something even faster so
having that as you're deployed up JSON
file gives it this deploy to Azure
button and when I click this it will
take me to a page where I can input
those parameters so in this case it's a
UI because I want to allow this to
anyone that goes to my github page I
want to allow them to create new
applications and you can see here that I
can select the subscription the research
group that I want to deploy this to and
the location but then there's also a
plain DB user DB password these are
parameters that I want to define in my
deployment template today whenever I'm
redeploying this I I want to I need to
specify a different app name does that
make sense yeah okay cool
another thing that I can deploy I can
configure is the storage account type
and you can see a cool thing is that I
can define default values so if nobody
specified these parameters I can I can
give a default value so that so that
people don't have to enter these and
also allowed values so that's super cool
as well the next thing that we can
define here is variables so these are
things that we're going to reuse
throughout our template there I'm not
necessarily immutable but these they're
not gonna change and we're gonna want to
use location in multiple for example
location and multiple multiple parts of
our our template and we don't want to
execute these functions for example
resource group that ID we can execute
this function we don't want to execute
it throughout our template and then
resources this is where the actual
description of the resources that we
need to deploy our define is defined so
you can see here that I need to in order
to deploy a function we need a storage
account where our code will will leave
we also need the app service plan which
is what we use for building an app
service which is where our code is going
to be deployed
and I think that's all so here we're
defining the storage account but I'm
gonna walk through this but before while
we're walking through the templates we
can go ahead and deploy the function
that I have in my local and I can do
that with the the same the same
extension which is the natural resource
tool manager something-something deploy
one of the Asha resource manager
templates in your workspace that's the
option that I care about and it says
that I have to log in first so as your
login it's giving me this annoying
interactive thing I have to paste in the
code continue and I'm now logged in
awesome so now if I try again deploy I'm
selecting the current folder where I
have to find the template and then I
will use an existing resource group
which is MVC London which I've created
previously and if I go to my portal to
the list of resource groups and search
for MVC London we're going to
immediately see that I've successfully
deployed two deployments and then I have
one that's in progress so I'm gonna
click on that one and I can monitor or
all the resources that are being
deployed for me we can see here that a
storage account has been deployed a
server forum that's the app service plan
and I can even see operation details so
some of the logs that are available for
us here and while that's happening we
can look at these these definitions
where I'm basically saying that I want
to deploy Microsoft app service plan
this is Microsoft websites and the name
is going to be the function app name
that we've used we've defined earlier
the location we're gonna retrieve that
from parameters its of type function app
and we can also define what it depends
on so this means that when we're
deploying those resources those are the
ones that are going to be deployed
before our site here and we can define
properties and in fact this is not gonna
work because I messed up the template
that we can generate using the extension
is using the older version of functions
which is one and an older version of
node so I've I've put in a PR this
weekend on to update these but it hasn't
been accepted yet so so this is where we
we specify those app settings this is
where we're gonna add our user
connection string this is where we're
gonna add anything that's that's
sensitive so let's see if this has been
deployed yes that's it has been deployed
we're gonna have to update the
application settings and the way we're
doing that is I can go into the portal
and instead of using six point five
point zero I'm actually going to use
eight eleven one which is the latest
node version and also the extension it
has to be two instead of one so see all
the app settings that we had in our arm
template there JSON template they're
reflected in the in the portal here and
I didn't have to do that manually that's
why I think the these arm templates are
so powerful I love them so I've saved
this and if I go to the overview page I
should be able to see the URL and it
tells me that the function is up and
running but actually we have no code
here right because we only deployed so
that arm template it's only describing
the infrastructure or the
the resources that we need so that we
can deploy that code to it so we know
our function app is running the next
step is deploying our code and I can
deploy my code using the right-click
deployment but what would be even more
interesting if was if I had my code in a
github account in a github repository
and then connect a CI CD pipeline to
always push my code to this particular
function app whenever I make a change so
I already have my code in on github
it's the repository you've seen earlier
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go to
Azure DevOps
so that's dev - sure calm and I can
configure a build pipeline right here so
in pipelines I have this builds screen
and I can create a new build and it's
gonna ask me where do you want to deploy
your code from I want to deploy it from
github and I want to use an existing
connection that's basically telling I've
authorized user' DevOps to read code
from my github account and then I want
to deploy this node bin our repository
and my repository already has this
pipelines that llamo file so you can see
here that I can define my build pipeline
using UML configuration you can also use
a UI for that I much rather have it in
code because this way it's versioned as
well so in this as your pipelines the ml
file I define what kind of image I want
to use to run my code and then to run my
build I want to also run npm install
remember in our code we depend on
MongoDB so we need to install that
package and then what I want to do is
archive my code together with my
packages and this is a task that's
predefined in Azure DevOps this is the
name of the task this is the display
name
the step that were executing right now
and then the next thing that I want to
do is publish that zip file to a
location in my Azure DevOps
environment and I'm gonna run this and
this will take me to a page to a
dashboard where I can I can see all
these steps that get executing executed
and there's a couple of things that we
can see on this screen how many you have
used VSDs before fantastic this is the
equivalent of VST as the newer version
is called DevOps pipelines and there's a
couple of things on this screen so we
can see first that's the last commit
message that I've the message for my
last comment on this repository then you
can see who made this commit we also
have a link to the actual repository
where we're reading data from we have
predefined the branch that we're using
and the commit number or hash and then
you can see the steps that we've defined
earlier with their names
so here npm install' archive files how
long that particular step takes we also
have access to the actual logs so here I
can inspect if something goes wrong I
can actually have a look what what
happened or what kind of commands have
been executed so now the green tick here
is it means that this step has finished
whereas the blue one it means that it's
still running it's in progress
another cool thing that we can see is
the number of seconds that we spent
during this build it's useful because if
you run this build for every single
commit and at some point something bad
happens it will take longer so you have
a history of how long your bill takes
and you can spot anomalies there but
from here so this is just building our
project on every single commit that I
make on github it will trigger this
build but our goal is to actually deploy
our code into the cloud right so I've
clicked on
release their I hope you've seen yeah
and I from my build I will be able to
create release as well and this is of
type app service deployment and in order
to define the properties here I'm gonna
have to use a subscription so in my this
is my subscription and then the type of
app that I want to deploy to is the
function app and then I want to deploy
what's the name of the function app that
I want to deploy to so remember we've
created NDC London so now I want to
deploy my code to that NDC London cobalt
and it's loading takes a while d5 is
that very perfect thank you okay so I'm
saving this and now I want to release it
so it's using the artifact that's been
created with the build and I can go into
this release and see again what's
happening right there so if everything
here works correctly my code will be
deployed to the new function app but if
we look at the at the function app
already that you might figure out that
there's one thing that we're missing
anyone can guess what was that
there you go perfect so set there has
the secret we are we are missing the
secrets right because we configured them
in our local but local that settings
that Jason where we have the details for
connecting to our database are never
deployed to the cloud they stay in our
local so now if I go into my list of
functions here I could either go to our
portal but we could also do this from
from the from vs code as well so if I
look here in DC London - if i refresh
that's my previous deployment my
previous attempt now we have NDC London
5 so from here I can access the
application settings that we've seen
earlier and we can see that we don't
have a user defined we don't have a
password defined I hope I won't break
the release maybe I'll just wait for
this to finish because this is pushing
my code and if I edit application
settings I I'll mess up with the I think
but basically what I can do is I can add
a new setting I can download remote
settings and I'm gonna do that because
you can see here do I want to override
as your web storage yes you can see here
that I have an instrumentation key for
monitoring applications and connection
string to the azure storage and I don't
have that in my local so I want to
download it and if I look at my local
that setting that Jason we can see these
new new settings
while that's happening I'll go back to
the applique to the function itself we
can see here that no function has no
code has been deployed I think now we
might have access because it's taking a
while to read that code but from here
from the overview page I have access to
application insights an application
insight that's what we use to monitor
our function so there's this screen that
I absolutely love that's the live
metrics screen and I'm gonna this is
gonna give me a real-time information
about what's happening with that with
our function and right now this is a
very bad screen where it's well it says
that my app is offline and that's that's
the case because we have just released
code to it so let me see if that
finished so we've succeeded and I want
to go back to our function and DC and we
can see our function our code has been
deployed here I can retrieve the URL
from this particular UI so gate function
URL I can copy it here and if I try to
access it because we don't have our
secrets it will give me an error saying
that an error has occurred and now I on
my application screen already we can see
that request that's coming in so let's
go ahead and now upload local settings
to our cloud and this has it will add
our user in our password so now if i
refresh this page it should give me data
from our database fingers crossed
this is usually not a good sign or it is
so this is data from coming from cosmos
TV and we can see the live metrics here
the second request which was successful
and I want to show you one last thing
how many of you have used the artillery
are you familiar with artillery MPM
package it artillery it's use is used
for load testing so what I can do with
artillery is now make a dozen of
requests to add your functions and show
you how we can see the requests coming
in and right now we can see that here we
have one server online but if I go ahead
and I'm actually gonna copy this so you
can install our artillery from NPM and
this is gonna start a quick test which
will run 10 requests and from 20 users
at the same time and I have to pass it
and the URL itself
let me go to my okay so we can see the
requests coming in the number of servers
increasing so this is scaling and also
if someone tells you that there's no
servers in several is you just take them
to the screen and then we will see it
happening you also have access to the
super name and how many requests per
seconds are coming in to a certain
instance running our code and this is
their output from artillery so I think
this is everything I have the last thing
that I actually want to show you
probably you've noticed that when where
we have our cloud our function in the
cloud the URL says recipes it doesn't
say read recipes the way we configured
that is in our function that JSON file
we can define a route so here you can
see that we can configure the method
that we're listening to which is here is
get but we can also configure route so
here we're saying that we don't we want
to override the name that we've given
the function and we want to configure it
to read from recipes to make to add
recipes to that okay so I think this is
a success this is definitely the demo
gods have helped me what have we managed
to do today we've managed to understand
what service is kind of we've managed to
create a new project in our local using
vs code and the vs code as your
functions extension we've also managed
to create a new arm template
infrastructure as code and we've
deployed the new function app and the
function using arm template we've also
configured the ICD so using Azure DevOps
we have we are now pushing codes to our
new function
on every single change that we make to
our repository and we've also seen how
we can use application insights to
monitor traffic that comes into our
function and obviously this will give us
so it will give us information about
whenever errors happen into our
application as well so far everything
has been successfully lucky me
so we haven't seen that but you can use
this screen for that as well if you're
looking to learn more about Asha
functions
oops about Asha functions and server
list in general and as your pipelines
have go to the these links you'll find a
lot of documentation I highly recommend
you check out Microsoft's third and
serverless those are modules they're
basically self-paced modules where you
can go in a sandbox the cloud shell will
be spun up for you and you can execute
commands there and you can learn about
server list you'll get points as well
and it's for free so you don't need an
azure subscription you can run your code
there as well and if you want stickers I
have some here so feel free to pop and
thank you so much
[Applause]